ideally doesn't want to swap the queens
he is currently a knight for a pawn down
he needs to keep the queens on the board
how can he do that i think he has to
step his queen up
defend the bishop david the queen is
going to get trapped in the middle of
the board
it's got no squares so now all magnus
needs to do is uh
attack it yeah so white's root can
actually bring itself up and trap the
black queen
that rook cannot be captured by a pawn
that pawn is pinned to the king krishuk
we saw him lean back there he suddenly
realized his queen is trapped
both players making expressions that's
not an easy move to see visually
but the black queen is trapped is about
to fall off the board
magnus is winning white has trapped the
black queen that's so rare to see a
queen trapped in the second second
i think the time is going to run out
while he figures that out yeah
he's losing on time he's losing on the
board yeah
really nice finish there by magnus
carlson and
yeah that's why we can't get in time
trouble in chess especially in such
complex
positions full of life horrible result
for alexander